it is time to step into the squared
circle where the only thing that makes
you holler is a dollar Chris Simms has
roared back and it has gotten close I
looked at the standings and went oh crap
it's time to get my game face on I have
completely changed my strategy for
betting this team does this on grass
event in 2015 were they gonna curb they
did this it's funny that a few weeks ago
he was like wow good information and now
he's going hey nerd what happened five
years ago does it was the squared circle
thing that confused me there you've
never heard of the phrase the squared
circle
I don't think called the wrestling ring
back in the day oh is that right I'm
stone-cold Steve Austin will face
Undertaker in the squared circle it's
hard to compare this to a wrestling ring
when we're sitting at a table shaped
like a fidgets spinner yeah when we were
designing this room he literally drew a
fidgets spinner and said I want the
table to look like this and now here we
not it's not an O Maj to fidget spinner
it is a fidgets but I just found if
three people were gonna talk to each
other
this shape table is very comfortable to
talk it it's nice to have the indented
no so I am going a lot more off of your
gut not as much gut but more eye your
gut you watch football trust it yeah
yeah that's right all right so let's see
how how close Simms is to me now all
right where were we before the lunar
eclipse the Dolphins no play good when
those things are right though it feels
really a I actually very much enjoy
listening to it because there are some
little bits and pieces so I I'm gonna
have it but I'm not I'm telling you that
I didn't base my picks off it like I
normally do okay so coming into coming
into week seven last week Sims you were
at minus 1060 Bleacher Box Lefko was at
- 450 Bleacher box a solid $700 gap a
solid lead coming into this week the gap
as close Sims you were at minus-6 10
left go you are at minus 600 it is a 10
dollar gap last week Sims you made 450
left go you lost 150 Sims your record
last week was seven six and one left go
your record last week was six seven and
one huh bringing the records to the
season with a better record yeah so for
the whole season Sims you are 49 54 and
three and left go is 51 52 and three all
right so that's where we're at
so again the only thing that your big
money bets the last two weeks I've had
paid off right you hit the Patriots last
week which you bet 600 on how did he bet
the week before why should I think it
was the Niners it was the Niners plugged
and I football against the Packer right
exactly right and that was what plus 5
or 600 that was a 500 year buck bet so
that was that's $1,000 going right to
you the last two weeks thank you had
your other your other big bet last week
was the 49ers for 200 did not hit that
one but dollars on the Patriots Beathard
man it's all I can say Beathard man all
I can say I mean we'll talk about that
but yeah I do think like Kyle actually
might have to the first time ever manage
his quarterback this week like just be
like don't I can't let him ask this game
up to you yeah I look at my bets and I
look at my bets last week
Dallas missing that field goal going to
overtime killed me that was $150 bet the
Chargers not beating the Tennessee
Titans by 30 which they seem to be on
pace to do it and letting that last
touchdown that was another 150 those
were killers yeah that's killer
I mean the NFL screwed you out of the
Cowboys game right you know I'm telling
you it when you lose money and there's a
call like that the first thing you want
to do is go this game's rigged the NFL
listens to the podcast no no I don't
think not the NFL ready to pick some
games here by the way yeah I'm rocking a
cafe mocha I'm hot chocolate right now I
got a half hot chocolate coffee I'm with
this it I'm such a better mood already
just because of liquid Oh warm liquid
and my tattoos are healing
it's good okay first game of the week
Thursday Night Football the four and
three Miami Dolphins on the road visit
by the way Sims what five and oh and
guaranteed to lose last what he did yeah
and you went two and two and left goes
LOX
yeah but five and OH on the season
you're twenty four and ten Oh still not
happy with that I'm going five a no this
week
okay you go to five and oh you're
working at that's almost like a 3210
yeah that's a three to one yeah that's
pretty good that's what we need to be
yeah okay first game of the week
Thursday Night Football Miami Dolphins
four and three on the road visiting the
four and three Houston Texans spread in
this game guys is Houston - seven and a
half and four every game today we have
decided we're going to Sims first yes
cuz if you go to me first then I talked
twice and then it's too much left code
not enough Simms Simms
taking it I know my weaknesses that's
good way to self scout interesting game
Thursday night Brock Tober okay everyone
I'm saying Brock I don't know why I do
like saying I don't even know why I'd
not even love with Brock Osweiler but I
like saying Brock Dale was fun the other
show that he does October gets thrown
around a lot yeah
either way okay so I look at it like
this the Houston Texans are certainly on
a rise as a football team right now but
at the same time I think we're overdoing
the fact that they're on the rises on
football team and let's look what
they've done the last few weeks right
one by three against the Cowboys you
know Buffalo Bills ugly game they're
right Nathan Peterman throws a pick six
you know they win the first game of
their four-game winning streak because
Reich decided to go for it in his own
40-yard line of more than one so again
I'm not gonna jump on this bandwagon
that like Houston's back they're going
in the right direction the thing I like
about the Texans is the run game is
coming there
I've liked what I've seen in past
protection the last two weeks where that
was my biggest concern and Jacksonville
never really got close to DeSean
throughout the game last week but I
thought this offensive line was abysmal
I know it's it's been better I don't
know what else to tell you there hey so
it's at least they're managing it and
they're not letting it ruin the football
game watching the defense is where I'm
encouraged because the defense is
starting to show signs of being able to
totally shut teams down we've talked
about it during the week
like Whitney Merciless looked as good as
he's looked in about a year and a half
last week against the Jacksonville
Jaguars clown he's back also we got to
play this into the fact here okay the
Houston Texans Brock Osweiler they don't
like him they don't yes I mean Bill
O'Brien wanted to beat Brock Osweiler up
in the locker room man he wanted to
fight him and they wanted to get after
it are you being serious that serious
yeah that's definite yes hold on so
you're telling me it was this after a
game you remember this the Titans game
there was an altercation when they were
kind of telling him he had to go back in
the game the last game of the year cuz
Savage remember they started savage and
then he got that gosh yeah you're just
forgetting about this well because it
was a meaningless game with none of
those teams did anything but I remember
Tom Savage laying on the turf yeah like
Joe Flacco after that hit from kiko a
lot exactly right wait so he got into a
fight yeah with Billy oh yes in the
locker room so that's always I know that
they traded Brock Osweiler the Browns
and gave away a second-round pick just
to get him out of talent that's like an
amazing thing when you hear Jadeveon
Clowney say things like hey we all know
defensive players want to hit the
quarterback but when they come out and
like or go I can't wait to hit Brock
that just tells you they didn't like him
either
okay so I look at that doesn't the other
thing that's kind of you worried about
Brock on Thursday they're gonna try to
whoop his ass I can tell you that much
they're gonna go look at that tall drink
of water over there we are gonna chop
him in the [ __ ] half okay but then
the other thing you gotta think about
this too which is this is where the
matchup gets a little personal
Osweiler's cases guy they were together
in Denver right now he's there he's been
playing better I will say that so I
think he will have a few tricks up his
sleeve when you go both ways and we
don't know which one you're gonna pick
in the game happen last night so excited
so okay I'm going a hundred dollars on
the Miami Dolphins huh don't feel
incredibly confident about this what are
you laughing at just you like doing the
dolphin movement but not making the
noise through the channels to get to
Houston you can do it but yes I'm taking
that what there was one other thing I
want to say oh the the
I looked for that concerns me the
Dolphins I mean they're run defense
pitiful pitiful mr miller kind of got
off last week well yeah that and the
Dolphins pass-rush has been
disappointing so there's two things
where I look at and go man they could
have had the advantage here and they
don't so that's why I'm going dolphins
fifty all right 100 hundred I can't
believe you putting $100 yeah I probably
shouldn't have but I had you know how I
do my formula I pick the games oh yeah
what was your final score
22:16 texans gotcha yeah I have $10 on
the Dolphins this game completely scares
me yeah
there are so many guys out for the
Texans Kiki Cote Ryan Griffin Zack
Fulton Brian Peters Aaron Colvin Cherise
right Andre how all-out yeah I have
hurts that's the one that I look at the
go oh look the the Texans have won four
games in a row during that span they're
two and two against the spread they're
horrible on Thursday nights one in six
straight up and against the spread the
last few years they haven't beaten a
spread at home this season but you look
at the Dolphins like they're there one
in seven all-time against the Texas like
all the things are bad but like the
Dolphins have Brock Osweiler and Albert
Wilson and Kenny Stills are hurt and I
feel like it's all about Kenyan Drake
breaking a run for a long game right
like that's what like but at the same
point seven and a half for the Texans no
one should be favored that much I feel
the same way about that as I did about
the Giants when they were favored by a
lot of the Giants the Giants won
outright but you know it's it's also
deshaun Watson taken a bus back to
Houston then play in a game in four days
yeah so I think it's a lot of points but
I think the Texans win this game yeah
but I think it's close yeah just like
Texans Cowboys right really close and
I'm only doing ten dollars I think
you're a sicko for but well I always
just here to Center it on everything
okay I don't do $10 bets I'm a baller
I'm rubberband man wilder than the
Taliban nine am i right for 25 in the
other hand yes that's what I am so I
don't do little $10 keep your Shanti's
odds that Josh knew what that was from
nothing zero
I was gonna go off 11 to one way okay
oh yeah oh yeah no I remember that King
King is one of the greatest albums ever
oh that urban legend man love that TI's
my man London you guys ready you sound
like 9:30 a.m. on Sunday morning the
three and four Philadelphia Eagles and
the three and four Jacksonville Jaguars
again what a game spread in this game
Philadelphia minus three and guys I'm
going to be prepared this week with
weather for every outdoor game in the
indoor games if you guys are just
curious about what's going on in the
cities where they have done I'd like to
know that weather in Wembley is going to
be on Sunday 41 degrees nope that's
Saturday I told you I was gonna be
prepared and I'm not prepared Sunday it
is gonna be Sunday sunny and a high of
51 winds out of the Northeast 17 miles
per hour oh that's cheeky weather the
Eagles Jake Elliott he's had issues
kicking into Northeast Jaguars may have
an advantage not being a winged animal
not relying very true thank you alright
Sam's take it away okay alright so my
big thing is this if you're the
Philadelphia Eagles I guess I could do
injuries first yeah go ahead do it Aries
first now I just I wasn't going to
transfer all right so injuries first
Darren Sproles still sidelined in
practice when speeders and Lane Johnson
were limited on Wednesday we know that
fur nets out DJ Hayden still sidelined
some of the guys that were limited on
Wednesday coleus Campbell and AJ Bowie a
so just is still the big thing with the
Jaguars as Blake bortles of starting
Leonard fournette snot playing again
yeah and he'll be back in two weeks
right
and Carlos Hyde can he do something this
week to help them out that watch right
you guys have the best certainly one of
the best run defense yes definitely in
the top five yeah
so I look at that alright so my big
thing is this the Eagles they really
kneeling for my money need to be worried
about one thing in this football game
they should win this football game in my
eyes mm-hmm it's they they're both about
or two in the NFL number two and the NFL
to me on this thing run defense yeah so
so the thing I look at for the Eagles is
go one thing matters in this game and
you'll win the football game
don't let the Jaguars defense win the
game don't call
since don't stand there for seven
seconds like he did at the end of the
game last week and try to think you're
gonna sit there in the pocket like magic
crap ain't gonna happen against
Jacksonville don't play that type of
game Plus Jacksonville is not gonna be
scared of the receivers of the
Philadelphia Eagles I think this is a
total slugfest type of football game I
mean the weakness of the Eagles defense
is their past II guess who they're
playing a team that can't throw it so
that doesn't matter
okay the weakness to the Jags D is still
their run D and I don't have a ton of
confidence in your run o at this point I
think that's better than what people
realize I think it's better than what
the Eagles realize I just wish they
would run more that's my big thing there
so if you're the Philadelphia Eagles
don't be afraid to win ugly I'm going
$100 on the Philadelphia Eagles and I
think they're gonna win this game 20 to
13 don't be afraid to win ugly Philly
that's stay away above stay high up in
the air Jaguar will eat you mr. eagle
stay up there don't come down okay okay
I say the score was gonna be I don't
know what you said listen I know rude
22:13 thank you I have my score as 21 to
20 okay I'm putting $10 on the
Jacksonville Jaguars whoa here's what I
need everyone to understand right now I
have such a bead on the Eagles that it's
not even okay right I know exactly who
this team is they are so much better
than the Jaguars and it's gonna feel
that way the entire game but there is
something about the Jaguars in London
that I do not feel comfortable betting
on I want you to know that I say at the
last two london weeks and it's been true
the favourites won both games 17 5 and 1
now but that the the favorite did not
cover the spread right the Jaguars have
been an underdog in three straight
London games and not only have they
covered they've won outright last year
there was nothing I was more confident
than the Baltimore Ravens having
destroyed two
teams in having ten turnovers in the
first two weeks and going and playing
Blake bortles in London sure and bortles
144 to seven and through four touchdowns
and no interceptions yeah it is a
different time that was the defense that
gave him the ball short field I know it
was that but they also had three
touchdowns to Mercedes Louis now I know
not on the team anymore Allen Hurns has
been big for the last three years not on
the team anymore Allen Robinson was big
not on the team anymore that's one thing
but what I keep thinking about is what
you said the Eagles try to just out
muscle you that's how they've played
these games yeah it's all Shaun Jeffrey
on deep comebacks it's Zach Ertz on
slants literally routes that are we're
bigger than you were stronger than you
and we're gonna make it move you know
what I haven't seen from the Eagles last
few weeks a deep ball touchdown haven't
seen one you haven't watched that once
it's the Titans game I'm watching long
drive yeah that are 1012 play much work
that our field goals are touchdowns at
the end yeah I don't like that against
Jacksonville
that's what Jacksonville loves sometimes
they give up the big play yeah I think
that this is an absolute slugfest yeah
and I think the Jaguars for some reason
might even have the lead here because of
what you said I do think Carson Wentz is
gonna hold the ball in too long I don't
think the running backs are gonna get to
the outside against this team I think
that special teams are gonna play a role
in this game I really don't like this
game at all but I do know that both
teams feel disrespected and that's why I
know that this isn't gonna be a game
that the Eagles kind of let slip away I
think it's a one-point Eagles win but I
do not think it's a cover yeah but I do
think that we are gonna have a few Blake
bortles passes I think we're gonna see a
DJ charkh pass that gets deep I think
the the Jaguars are the team that gets
the big plays and the Eagles are the
team that maintains the long drive but I
think in the end they win and I but I
think it's really close I agree I'm
really yeah I picked oh 22:13 game I
think it's going to be like a 1713 late
field Gold make Jacksonville score yeah
alright guys moving on to the one
o'clock games on Sunday the thigh hole
before I just don't think I am with this
team I think Lefko and I are doing
mimosa Sunday morning mimosas yeah in
the office cuz we're gonna be here for
the game at 9:30 a.m. not check us out
at Sims in love Co dude you are more
than welcome to come in for any week is
our first year that we haven't watched
games together now let's feel a little
lonely yeah I hear ya it's we should
also come up there but I have I have
work when do you have worked this
weekend I do what do you mean I'm on the
pregame for Sunday Night Football
oh you're on the pregame this week I am
I didn't know that yes now you do so
you're doing New Orleans Minnesota I am
alright so I'll watch you Sunday night
hey thanks for watching me now the whole
country gets to hear you say that drew
Brees is one of the top 12 quarterbacks
in the history of the NFL wait till they
hear Michael Thomas and I just can't
believe cam Jordan went the whole dad
angle on me yeah come on I mean his dad
played in the NFL too like we really mmm
my guts that's maybe he was deflecting
because he's self-conscious does he know
how much we stick up for him we'll get
him here one time we'll talk it out yeah
that's just a cheap shot yes you guys
are very defensive athlete one o'clock
slate on Sunday first game is the three
and four Denver Broncos on the road
visiting the six and one Kansas City
Chiefs spread in this game Kansas City
minus 10 and the weather in Kansas City
Missouri on Sunday 63 is the high 40 is
the low mostly sunny wind's coming out
of the Northwest 16 miles an hour
mm-hmm just something to keep in mind
yeah all right you have no injuries for
the Broncos the away team Royce Freeman
weren't missed Wednesday's practice with
an ankle injury the other people that
missed Jared Jared Ville dear again yeah
like third or fourth week in a row right
Shane ray Darian Stewart excuse me did
not practice hot chocolate hit me in the
gut Darian Stewart the safety neck
injury okay Chiefs the only three
players who didn't practice in full are
the three key starters that have been
missing which is Eric Berry Justin you
shouldn't miss Mitch Morse okay so those
guys missed last week is there any
update with Houston or Mitch Morris
about close they are
Houston hamstring Mitch Moore's
concussion no I could see Mitch Morse
maybe coming back this week and I can't
plate I haven't heard about Eric Barry I
mean how much longer is this gonna go on
with this heal thing remember that heal
thing they came out that story a few
weeks ago
that's a degenerative heals oh geez Eric
Berry is one of those guys that when he
comes back it truly is an appreciation
for how hard that dude battles yes
seriously cancer heal injuries it's tour
last year okay so I hear you there
all right I I think listen and the
Chiefs are favored by ten yes oh yeah
that's a lot of points especially I'll
say this I mean the the Broncos match up
well with the Chiefs okay I just look at
it like that the Broncos have pass
rushers let's come alive a little bit
they have good pass coverage they got
guys that certainly can hold their own
when they need to here and there you
know you're not gonna make a living
playing man-to-man against Kansas City
or your ass is gonna be toast but they
can do it on certain plays to be
creative and do something different you
know on the other side of the ball when
I look at like the Chiefs of course
their defense is not special and I think
the Broncos are a team that realizes
like they're in desperation mode right
now this is Vance Joseph fighting for
his life
they had extra days prepare got their
offense going a little bit last week of
course I'm still concerned with Kansas
City's defense um I think the thing that
concerns we do is like Denver you know
hey Denver's pass offense they're not a
dink and dunk type offense they want to
throw the ball and be aggressive - and
that's why Case Keenum could throw an
interception here and there and do those
type of things
listen I think Kansas City wins this
game
I don't think Kansas City will be
patient enough with the run game just to
knock Denver's dick in the dirt okay and
then the game that's a technical term
sounds like it yes and sounds really
gross and I think because of the things
I've said plus the human factor of the
Chiefs have played two prime time games
two weeks in a row one they lost one
they won but either way those are
emotional things and it is something to
be I think they're not at their best so
I'm going a hundred dollars on the
Denver Broncos Wow I think the Chiefs
win the game third but I think the
Chiefs win the game 3224 something along
those lines but I think this game's
gonna stay close for a little while
I don't think they're gonna let it slip
away I just think they'll be too much at
the end before you go left go yeah I
have to point this out week one Sims
took the Chargers - three and a half
against the Chiefs week - you took
Pittsburgh - four against the Chiefs
week three you took San Francisco plus
six and a half against the Chiefs week
four you took Denver plus four and a
half against the Chiefs did I miss that
one no you hit that one it was the first
one you had they not win by four and a
half I mean it was really close they did
not cover so I lost it up okay yeah yep
you're right week five you took you took
Jacksonville plus three this is amazing
yeah Maddie
yep week six was New England I took New
England you took New England lost that
one and week seven you took Cincinnati
and lost perfect because there is no
team in the event every week yeah
there's no team on the edge no this week
yeah they're seven and no against the
spread right your Owen seven betting on
the Chiefs
okay I don't really care about that stat
because no no he did he did cover it
with the Broncos because I don't know
how we got it for them he got at a four
and a half was three and a half and it
was 27 23 I was off I was very close to
hitting with the Patriots game
the Broncos game I hit but I listen I I
guess I got up I want to ask you one
question yes when the Chiefs played at
the Broncos on Monday Night Football
would you say that was nearly a perfect
execution
for the Broncos in that game to put the
Chiefs in a situation when they were
down ten with eight minutes left
yeah yes yep perfect right in Denver
right Denver's arguably the best game
they've played all season yeah
Kansas City not only beat them they
covered and they stole their soul sure
Kansas City knows exactly what's gonna
happen in this game this is going to be
one of my left koloff's
I'm putting $100 on Kansas City - ten
there seven and all against the spread
they're 11 and no against the spread
their last 11 games going to last year
against the AFC West they're 14 and one
right against the spread they're 12 and
three man can't beat Denver it's about
the Denver
six in a row and they've covered every
single time and everything just says
this is the time I thought we weren't
doing trends this way yeah but this is
one of those where I feel really good
about it because I look at Kansas City
and what did you just say about Case
Keenum he takes the big shot right what
do I want defenses to do against Kansas
City when I play them I want them to go
for the big shot
I'm afraid of the teams that can move
the ball I'm afraid of the teams that
can put together drives and keep Patrick
mahomes because I'll take the Chiefs in
a shootout with the Broncos with a
ten-point spread all day because Case
Keenum is gonna lob it up and that's
when Orlando Scandrick makes the one
play that's the one time that Kendall
Fuller makes the one play please those
guys now now you're gonna go please give
it to them yeah yeah I got the matchup
advantage on Sutton and Emmanuel
Demaryius Jennifer has dinner has been
hearing all week right Emmanuel Sanders
is on the trade block
Demaryius Thomas is on the trade block
Roby's on the trade block they got an
overinflated ego from getting to pick
sixes against Josh Rosen on a Thursday
night football game and they're coming
in here feeling crispy and they're about
to go to Arrowhead where Patrick mahomes
is about to hang a 45 burger and that my
prediction for this game what was your
score 32 24 it's great it's gonna be 45
to 10 Chiefs oh my gosh what do you bet
on it hundred oh well that's you're a
wuss I have nothing you can't come that
straw I got a lot of cash coming later
Sims don't worry you can call me the ATM
block and you're only $100 that's a
[ __ ] week lock I don't know what else
to tell you yeah you know what else is
week lock that haircut wait a couple of
people comment on your haircut good show
I look good go back and forth no big
haircut let me ask you hold on you know
I think it plays into the favor that the
Broncos have seen this team already and
then know that they can do this like I
also having to play the Rams a few weeks
ago losing a close game to them I just
think it plays into their favor to see
some of these high-octane offenses and
realize that like man we had our chances
to win these football games I don't
think they win but I just think they're
getting forty five to ten you're forty
five to ten
and again forty five to ten and what
about in a hundred dollars they played
the Rams at home they lost to the Jets
by 18 on the road they lost by 13 on the
road at Baltimore they're going into
Arrowhead Andy Reid is trying I feel
this the one thing I want to do Josh
does his bets with his brother too
right what do you think about this game
we even talked yet okay but what do you
listening to us I I am NOT gonna bet
against the Chiefs until they prove to
me that I should bet against them but I
mean he is the Oracle so that's okay I
don't have to be right here we'll say
I'm just I'm going with a little G would
you like to make another $20 bit about
them covering the spread yeah sure you
guys want to put it in I don't shake
your hand I don't know where it's been
you don't want to shake my hand in this
case right now pound it pound it fist me
real $20 bet okay me to hold the 20s
this week I don't think he's got money
probably not all right broke-ass next
game on the one o'clock slate the two
four and one Cleveland Browns on the
road visiting the three two and one
Pittsburgh steel wallet what are you an
old man cheese I thought left go was
about to give me a ten a five okay so
the Cleveland Pittsburgh spread
Pittsburgh minus eight and a half and
the weather in Pittsburgh on Sunday high
of 49 low of 42 showers and nine mile an
hour winds coming out of the southwest
showers huh showers yeah 40% chance of
precipitation sunrise 7:45 in the
morning and Pinterest interesting all
right Browns were missing damarious
Randall Joe Schobert
and JC Treader at Wednesday's practice
to Marius Randall being the biggest name
there the only did not practice that was
injury related for the Steelers Marcus
Gilbert was a did not practice and
Morgan Burnett for the Steelers back ok
practicing in full and again where in
the world is Le'Veon Bell no one knows
this spread started at 7 and it's now up
to 8 and a half it's up to 8 and a half
all right Sims II all right so I guess
the first thing that concerns me is the
Browns defense in this matchup
right the Browns defense has just been
getting shredded lately pass game run
game doesn't really matter it's very
concerning to me you know the Steelers I
know they're not a great running
football team
but at the same time you have to respect
it to a degree it's not like a kind of
run game or you can just go well they
can't run the ball we don't ever have to
worry about it no they can run the ball
enough to where you can't just abandon
playing run defense all together
the Steelers offense the way they kind
of went into the by I think was a
positive thing they certainly have their
mojo going as far as play Atlanta put up
some big plays we know that I know it's
Atlanta's defense but getting a big win
in Cincinnati all those things I liked
I do think also that the the Steelers
defense has been we've been playing
better but better football as of late I
don't know if I have enough confidence
and again I know we have the Todd Haley
familiarity matchup and all that I just
don't know if I have the confidence in
the Cleveland Browns offense to be
consistently good my big thing with the
Cleveland Browns if they want to win
this game and keep it really close it's
going to come down to their run game if
they can run the ball with Nick Chubb
and kind of control the clock and do
that then they can keep this game
somewhat close I'm not sure if they can
totally do that I think that again the
Steelers their secondary it's been
better lately I've I've liked what I've
seen you know again zones are more sound
they're not a team that wants to live in
man but they've shown the ability to do
it just here and there I think when it
all comes said and done too you know
it's gonna piss the Steelers off about
the week one tie they're gonna look at
that game and watch the film go damn we
blew that like there's no way but either
way eight and a half points was just a
hair too much for me so I'm putting $50
on the Browns here
her I picked the Steelers to win the
game 28 to 20 mm-hmm and as you'll see
here all my $50 bets are ones that I've
either either have picked the push to be
the spread or I'm like a point five off
you picked 28 to 20 before you saw the
spread 100% swear on my kids donut don't
do that I just I get on the train I
start to pick my scores yeah about the
matchups and I go and then I go from
there
I am also putting $50 on the brass so
this is a wash price my main thing is
just like you I do not believe the
Browns are capable of winning this game
right but I do think eight and a half is
too much and I also have a theory I have
a few teams this week that I'm calling
my sleepwalkers these are my teams
coming off a bye that I think that they
start slow after byes I'll tell you the
other one a little bit later but the
Steelers to me are one last five years
they're one in four against the spread
coming off a bye I also think and tell
me if I'm crazy here I feel like the
more emotional coaches sometimes it
takes their teams a little bit more to
to kind of get up to form I think about
you know the Tomlin's of the world and I
feel like he's not that great early in
the year I feel like it takes a little
bit of clicking did you agree with that
yeah I would yes I mean yeah yes I do I
also think the Browns have actually
played the Steelers really well last few
years you look at all those games not
only are they coming they're covering
the spread you know they got to tie a
little bit earlier I just think the
Steelers are gonna start off a little
bit rough and I think the eight and a
half could end up being too much um yeah
and I just think it's too many points
yeah but I think the Steelers win yeah I
did you see it is the and the Steelers
run defense is pretty good the only way
I could see it is it's just the Browns
start manhandle in the run game it's the
only way they have a chance and I just
I'm not gonna bet on that
all right guys next game on the one
o'clock slate here for into Washington
and coming up to visit the one-in-six
New York Giants spread in this game is
Washington minus one whether in New
Jersey on Sunday it's gonna be partly
cloudy high of 55 low of 45 8 mile an
hour winds and a small chance of rain so
just factor that into your predictions
okay was this one of the law
that you looked at and went what the f
well I mean after I picked the score I
was a little bit like that but I can get
it I get it this is one of those games
that everything in my heart made me want
to load up on Washington and then I went
something's not right here I'm being led
into a booby trap right I'm gonna lower
my bet I'm gonna lead honestly there's a
ton of Washington players on the injury
report they're really banged up right
now but a lot of those guys like Adrian
Peterson are just they're gonna rest on
Wednesdays the rest of the year without
question Giants was the Alec Ogletree
was the only one that didn't start
obviously snacks traded Eli Apple traded
I look at this and I was like you're
telling me I just have to pick
Washington to win but I think I also
looked back and realized that Washington
is like one in four in their last five
trips to New York so it's just one of
those divisional games that scares me
I'm putting $100 on Washington just
because I think they're the better team
I had this at 200 and I brought it back
because I went what if Odell slips one
through and it's just a weird game
because I don't really have that much
faith in Washington but I know that the
giant should be dead
yes I think that's the biggest thing
that play all right so I'll just get it
out of the way too
I'm bowing $100 on the Redskins as well
we need it we need a hail to the
Redskins song I think for the Redskins I
think that's B but are you your dude red
skins sorry did you also know something
about this feels weird without a doubt
and even I picked the Redskins to win 23
to 13 that's what I'm saying but I was
like I'm not going to bet more money on
Alex Smith and the Redskins up in New
York I'm just not I don't trust it all
the way so that I'm also weirded out
remember when the Giants were like oh
and four and they went to Denver right
and they won that game and I'm like I
don't know man this is like a giant well
a like it can go either way so this is
where I this is where the game scares me
my heart of hearts wants to say the
Giants aren't gonna play very good this
week it's finally over they
realize that the season's over oh it's
over the organization is emitted
admitting that this week by trading Eli
Apple and Damon snacks our seed Shermer
and Eli's quotes today it's not a little
reason not over according to the coach
to the quarterback oh okay yeah
it's either a Giants zombie game where
you think of teams dead and they go back
to life where it's the official close
the casket game but I just I first like
the zombie game I'm nervous it does make
me nervous but you also got to put $100
on there because you're like everything
in my mind says this makes sense yes and
you know I think the other thing too
with you know the Redskins their defense
is good it's really good don't let the
one Monday night game off a bye week
against the Saints fool everybody um
that's an outlier they blew some
coverages they did some dumb crap that
night they got Sean Payton they did they
do it they have John Jeffries new record
right there was a lot of emotions that
played into that football and the
Superdome maintains emotions man they'd
lock us up and I look at the Redskins
and you know again their offensive side
of the ball I don't see how the Giants
are gonna get a huge pass rush on them
and I would expect the Redskins the
Redskins have the capabilities to be one
of the better run teams in football and
I'm gonna say it again
the Redskins need to be a power run
football team and what a better time to
do it than when a team trades their
number one run stop exactly that's
that's what I mean so that's why I
picked the game to be 23 to 13 wins by
20 we're like why didn't we do this
fishy machine ever since I've been a
little kid the Giants have had the
Redskins number I don't know what that
is so I pump the brakes and I only went
a hundred yeah
all right guys next game here is the
three and three Seattle Seahawks on the
road visiting the three and three
Detroit Lions spread in this game is
Detroit - three do you guys want the
weather in Detroit yes just want to know
I do Sunday in Detroit it's gonna be a
high of 47 low of 36 cloudy and 20%
chance of rain 7 mile an hour winds so
it's not gonna affect the game
I don't know is it nice to wake up in a
city and have the Sun out when you're at
the hotel yeah it gives you a good vibe
you're like ah it's a beautiful day for
us to go out there and whoop their ass
alright so maybe the clouds and
today well then the Seahawks are gonna
wake up on a Radisson and go [ __ ] to
Troy yeah what do we do well there use
the grey weather - all right only only
Seahawks players to miss practice coming
off of thereby as chair and read Detroit
had a few guys missing practice Theo
Riddick miss practice Jared Davis
starting linebacker was a DNP with a
calf but Golden Tate Zeke Ezekiel Anza
and Darius slay all limited it'd be the
first time is Eagle on someplace in a
few weeks and again snacks likely will
be in the lineup I don't assume right
I would assume to I mean that is that is
the question does you know does he play
how much does he play I mean he's
obviously in game shape and really I
think it would be rules and this defense
of the map Patricia would be something
that he's used to because he's played in
the Rex Ryan defense so that has some
similar nose tackle rules and even this
defense he played with the New York
Giants and James Boettcher yeah same
thing you know there's some similar
rules there so I don't think it's gonna
be like a huge learning curve either way
excited about this game I worry listen
the run defense of the Detroit Lions
yeah it scares me there's no doubt and
the Seahawks are the type of team that
they're run offenses it's becoming
special I don't know any other way to
say it they really are and so the
seventh best run offense in football
okay so you look at that what they do
now there is some history with Patricia
on the New England staff against
Schottenheimer when he was with the Jets
so he should know that to a degree other
thing that scares me on this side of the
ball is you know
Ezekiel odds of being back great as he
gonna really be the guy we know him to
be no I worry about these kind of games
on that surface russell wilson can take
over at certain moments and just go I'm
gonna run around back here and you won't
catch me and I'll throw a 40-yard pass
the Doug Baldwin eat that Detroit now on
the other side of the ball I worry about
the same thing with the Seahawks I don't
know if they could stop the run the
lines the Lions run offense is real real
real deal Holyfield Matt Stafford
I think fix some issues he had with his
mechanics over the bye week he may
some throws last week that I went
there's Matt Stafford and it just I'm
again I'm not even talking some of the
even the incompletions where I just go
he threw that exactly where he wanted to
it was a tight spiral so I think he made
the adjustments there now I think let me
just get my thoughts here okay I know
when my bet is I just wanted to make one
more points um I think though my biggest
issue here is I don't think the Seahawks
the Seahawks have played one real
complete offense their whole year okay
and that was the Rams then the Rams put
up 31 points or 33 points against yeah
in Seattle so is I know the Seahawks are
up there in total defense ranking but I
don't really buy into the numbers all
the way like I think if I kept it as a
total I would go there really like a
middle of the road type defense in the
NFL for me they're not a top ten top
five they're in that category cuz they
played some very stagnant offenses in
the Cowboys the Cardinals true Biscay
through some bad picks early on oh they
got the Raiders and that dumpster fire
there so that's where I look at as an
issue so at the end of the day I am
going $50 on the Detroit Lions don't
care about vendrick and your frickin
[ __ ] reversible clause I'm a [ __ ]
lion and I'll eat you in a heartbeat and
COFF up the feathers okay I'm picking
this Lions ode to win the game 27 24 and
I'm only going 50 because I think this
is a very evenly matched game mmm this
is the left go betting extravaganza
matchup of the week whoo nothing aligns
better from a game flow perspective
interested theory my mind right in this
game I have looked back one this is just
a betting line for you Sims what do you
think the liens are against the spread
this year without yeah they are how many
games are they played six there are five
and one oh I was gonna say it's good I
wasn't go forward - only thing they lost
that Jets game yeah
here is why I love this game with all of
my heart the Seattle Seahawks are part
of my sleepwalkers we are sleepwalking
in Seattle last year off the bye I'm
gonna go into that big old brain of
yours right after by they go to New York
and they win 24 to 7 but what do you
remember about that game since it was in
New York it was the Giants yes they were
in 24 - 7 you should remember that with
10 minutes to go in the fourth
they were only leading 10 7 yeah yeah
really not what were the latest
touchdown a Baldwin right late touchdown
the Marshall I believe it was it was
like oh and then we came back and looked
at each other and said wow they really
started off pretty poorly there right
two years ago they beat Atlanta 26 to 24
what do you remember about that game
five minutes left in the fourth
they're down 24 to 17 that was the big
Tevin Coleman Devonta Freeman game that
was the head slap pass interference yes
and call that was the [ __ ] Oh Jones
penalty where they didn't call Pass
interfere right three years ago off the
bye they lose to Arizona 39 to 32 that
game second quarter Arizona's up 19 to
nothing wow Seattle comes out of the by
slow and that was with Earl Thomas and
that was not return being in London for
a few days and having a 9-hour time
difference in the 10 hour time
difference near life Detroit at home
yeah
their last two games at home the first
half scores they outscored Green Bay and
New England 37 to three this is the Adam
left go first half bet the Detroit Lions
whatever the spread is they are going to
build a huge lead and they have to
withstand the comeback of Russell Wilson
right I believe that that running game
that you're so worried about isn't going
to be a factor in this game yeah because
I think Matt Stafford and Golden Tate
and Kenny gala day and all those guys
jump out to an early lead and the
Seahawks
can't rely on the run and when they do
you're gonna get snacks Harrison like
the one thing that they were bad at they
may have just gotten the fix in this
right I really love Detroit
- three I'm going $200 on Detroit I
think that this is the game flow game of
the week I love it I'm not mad at Vince
I'm not mad at ya I'm not mad at you no
those are some good stats that I like
that right I did I just I to me Seattle
and Pittsburgh emotional head coaches
that have to get their teams riled up
coming off of a bye against a team
that's like starting to click right now
I really it just feels good and what you
said who are the quarterbacks at
Seattle's faced yeah who are the
offenses that we've seen the Legion of
boom up against like oh they had success
against try Biscay they wouldn't have if
he if he was able to complete on pit
easy pass like Stafford against the
Seahawks defense is a great matchup like
those wide receivers against that
defense it just feels really good for me
yeah I had a lot of good logic there and
I love the Detroit Lions right now I
kind of get known that Jay I'm rooting
for him too I can't trust it yet like
that but I'm rooting for him it's gonna
be hard for me to root against them now
that you bet that money boy do I have a
stat for this next game next game on the
one o'clock slate here these are really
good these are not where I'm typically
getting my stats from these were the let
me do some left Co investigations their
natural dish they're organic tips oh I
like or self-sustained Organic is good
artisan alright 3 & 3 Tampa Bay going on
the road to visit the 4 and 3 Cincinnati
Bengals spread in this game is
Cincinnati - four and a half
whether it's Cincinnati on Sunday high
of 54 low of 43 we've got rain in the
forecast guys Oh 60% chance of rain on
11 mile an hour winds I'm gonna tell you
what the Bengals and Buccaneers in a
rainstorm love it that a football can I
take the over and turnovers see Dalton
and Jameis gonna be slinging that around
here Peyton Barbour missed practice
we're going to could this be the Ronald
Jones show Gerald McCoy
curry miss practice again right now good
Bengals had ten players missing from
practice Ross
John Ross groin vantes Burfict hip nick
vigil knee dark has Denard sterno
clavicular which I guess is tournament
article so up here and then Dre
Kirkpatrick Achilles were just five of
the ten but both teams are banged up
both teams are not reliable it's a wild
game Chris Simms it is a wild game a lot
of explosive offensive players on the
field - horrible defenses the Bengals
can't stop anything the pass or the run
but the Bucs can't run so I'm not really
all that concerned with that aspect of
the football game you know the
Buccaneers their defense they can't stop
the pass either I'm just gonna put it
simple like this when I look at this
game it just comes back both these suck
neither team can run the ball doesn't
matter I'm just gonna take the Bengals
at home because I trust that they have a
few more playmakers on their overall
football team than the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers so because of that I'm going
$50 only on the bet on the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers excuse me
because I think the Bengals will win
this game 31 to 27 I think we can you
put $50 on who the Bucs yo ho yo hold
the pirate's life for me yes I don't
think they're gonna get blown out here
they're gonna move the ball up and down
the field on the Kansas City Chiefs got
ourselves a flipper I'm going $50 on
Cincinnati when I see it except that was
a long one
[Music]
he's pissed this dang that's an angry
Bengal Diaz pissed and hungry
that's like sometimes I follow that
account black Jaguar white tiger or
whatever it is yeah and I saw one we're
like one of the Panthers took like a hat
and they were like try to get the Hat it
was like it like went on for like a
minute that was that was really again
I've done that so many times it sounded
especially real today yeah it really did
I was good he slowed it down I think
that's okay Cincinnati left got alright
so I I think that these are two teams
that are the only reason I'm putting $50
is because I have a stat that I really
really like right and I didn't want to
put $10 on it I hate both of these teams
I think that both of them are unreliable
I feel like Cincinnati's won some games
that they shouldn't have won the
Dolphins game I feel like the Buccaneers
lose games to the Falcons they should
win and win games against the Browns
they probably should have lost I don't
like either of their quarterbacks I find
them unreliable I think both of the
coaches are in over their heads and I
think they're both banged up I don't
like this football game I don't want to
watch this football game it'll be
entertaining but for all the wrong
reasons
but I went to Pro Football Reference
yeah and I just said
how's Jameis on the road and I looked it
up
Sims the last ten times that Jameis
Winston has played in a road game so
this includes the Bears game that he
came in and some of the other games what
do you think his record is straight up
on the road
one in nine oh and ten didn't he beat
the Falcons on the road last year in
Atlanta no he did not
that was two years ago the one they went
one in seven on the road last year you
know their one win was Ryan Fitzpatrick
in Miami hmm Jameis Winston on the road
I feel like is where we see all of those
plays where we go and that's the other
side of Jameis Winston where he throws
the ball after he ran over the line of
scrimmage for five yards or he's getting
sacked and he throws it up in the air
and then Carlos Dunlap runs it in for a
touchdown
the bangles are coming off of this is
the reason I went with the Bengals here
the Bengals are coming off of an
embarrassment on Sunday Night Football
where I don't even think they played
especially bad they just met a chainsaw
and the Kansas City Chiefs were like oh
no we're gonna keep your face down on
the ground Tampa Bay won on a 59 yard
field goal by Chandler Catanzaro after
they tried to blow the game five times
at home something is wrong with the Bucs
offense when I watched that game they
almost have too many weapons that Jameis
doesn't know what to do he tries to
force it to Mike Evans and he comes back
to OJ Howard then he looks down at the
running backs and he's got gotta get
four attempts to Adam Humphries he's
looking for Godwin and then it's
reverses to DeSean Jackson they don't
know what they're doing yet right
they're all over the place
the Bengals though for me when I saw
Jameis hasn't been a part of a win on
the road and ten games right my fear is
that he's gonna cut it close and somehow
cover that spread but I'm gonna take the
Bengals I think at the end of the year
the Bengals are a better team and so I'm
picking them to win this game okay yeah
I mean I'm picking him to win to just
they didn't cover by 0.5 how about that
oh and ten that's pretty amazing
it really is next I was surprised I I'm
me too but I mean he's listen he's the
quarterback of a bad football team so I
don't know he's the quarterback of a bad
friend always helped out I think it's
okay to say that like we're really quick
about a little rant so the Giants are
blowing it up right and the reason I get
upset that the Giants are blowing it up
is because they told us they weren't
going to blow it up yeah
like have a plan stick to the plan have
a focus know what your goals are the
Tampa Bay Bucs I don't think I've had a
plan now for 3-4 years I think they go
into every game trying to rewrite the
rule book
I honestly think and I don't wish for
anyone to lose their jobs but I think
they need a complete regime change I
think that the quarterback the coach and
the GM they need to start over I don't
think they have any building pieces to
start on they've wasted Gerald McCoy's
prime their offensive line is starting
to come together it's starting to make
sense they have really good receivers
but I don't see anything to build on in
that franchise yeah nothing about that
seems like a stable
nation it was supposed to be Jamis but
he's not stable I think that Jameis is
representative of that franchise as a
whole I think it all needs to start over
I mean I think there's a very good
possibility that's where it goes when
and to be honest you know I also I would
start over yeah because the Falcons
their quarterback is in the 30s Drew
Brees is coming near an end Cam Newton
is start you need to you're not going to
win this next 3-4 years if you're the
Bucks right the Saints the Falcons and
Panthers are in their window this is
where it is you need to start rebuilding
now so that in three four years as all
those guys that's when you take over
just just mail it in it's over start
over that's how I would do if I wasn't
looking yeah III think there's a very
real possibility that can happen I did
not expect us to break down this game
for 15 minutes there's always one every
week there's always one every week Colts
bills dollars $50 okay
Colt Bills last week that was cold
spills right right okay next game here
on the one o'clock slate to the three
and four New York Jets on the road in
Chicago visiting the three and three
Chicago Bears spread in this game is
Chicago - seven weather on Sunday it's
gonna be a high of 50 low of 41 lot of
rain across the NFL on Sunday guys
showers 50% chance of rain and 13 mile
an hour winds left go
the injury's jets are still banged up a
noon well Robbie Anderson shermaine
Johnson Morris Claiborne Bulow Powell on
IR neck injuries I want to send out
wishes to that guy yeah they're saying
it might be career-ending talk about a
guy that runs hard in this league and
yeah I don't know if he ever got his
payday no he did not
and that's one of those things that
hurts my heart Isaiah Crowell did
practice and full get the bulk of the
carries for the Bears Allen Robinson
groin toradol
Khalil Mac ankle missed practice yeah
you were words about Khalil Mackel Mac
have been just like bringing your
ringing in my head I'm actually gonna do
my bet first I'm doing the Jets $10
because
I'm doing Jets $10 because I don't
really trust the Bears that much to
cover a seven-point spread but I also
don't trust the Jets with what they have
so on I don't like this game at all I'm
going $10 Jets yeah I hear you my
breakdown of the game would be more this
okay both teams can run the football
they both have the ability to run the
football on both sides of the ball and I
look at that and sure brewskis running
is a a true weapon I mean that's what we
saw last week and that could be a pain
in the butt for the New York Jets
especially because they not they are not
a team that has incredible speed on the
edge of their defense so I look at that
aspect of it the other thing is I look
at the Jets and go for them to win
football games they have to kind of
dominate in the run game and they're not
gonna dominate this bears defensive
front
not in the run game there's no way I
just don't see that happening
the other thing that scares me about the
Jets is they do let up a lot of big
plays you know they can have moments
where yeah you go oh this looks good two
or three two or three drives they've
gone three nowt the defense is stopping
them but then all sudden they let up a
bomb by Kirk Cousins so where you know
it's Andrew Luck with a big play down
the field too many of those instances
Jaguars game right that just scare me
with little matchups like that leaving
Darryl Roberts on our island and things
like that
they're just you know too many times
eventually he's going to get burned I
worry about in Chicago windy field still
Sam d'Arnaud struggled throwing the ball
in the wind last week anyway yeah I mean
he made some throws where I think he
thought like oh I'm throwing to an open
guy and I'm gonna complete this oh damn
the wind hit it in it instead of being a
90 mile per hour fastball it went to
like 65 how much you got the Bears
winning this game by so this is uh this
is the thing I'm going $50 on the Bears
I picked the game to be 24 to 17 mmm
damn yeah and I just I know and I just
can't
um I can't bet too much money here
either way cuz I don't trust the Bears
no the Bears have to be pissed off I do
agree with you right you're betting on
the team
that when we watch the game you're gonna
be in control the entire time right they
might lose and f it up there's no doubt
about it the Bears have to screw it over
to lose this game I think so the Bears
will have control it's right do you get
the random Robbie Anderson touchdown
right or is it the Jets break a big run
broken a big run right and I screw it up
right yeah yeah and I just think that
you will definitely feel more sure the
whole game than I will yes what you bet
50 in the head 10 I don't want this game
yeah it's scary I totally feel that the
real thing is is either quarterback can
ruin this for us again and that's and my
thing was is I kept thinking about
Khalil Mak not being healthy and I went
you know what like I just I don't know
if they're realizing that what Khalil
Mack isn't yet and I'm trying to jump in
while yeah yeah I get you I get you all
right guys last game on the one o'clock
slate on Sunday great 143 Baltimore
Ravens on the road visiting the 4 and 2
Carolina Panthers spread in this game
Ravens minus 2 and the weather in
Charlotte on Sunday high of 66 low of 48
sunny all day 8 mile an hour winds out
of the southwest
so little scary injuries for Baltimore
doesn't mean these guys are gonna miss
but three starting corners missed
practice on Wednesday yeah Jimmy Smith
with a groin Brandon Carr with a knee
Marlon Humphrey with a thigh so all in
those legs areas I guess New Orleans
blocks low yeah banging those guys up
they do Torrey Smith Mario Addison
missed practice Cam Newton limited with
a shoulder injury but we know can do in
a mess of nothing now this is this is I
think up there with Kansas City Denver
and with Seattle Detroit as the game of
the one o'clock yeah I'm extremely
excited about this football game this
might be the game it really it really
might be I look at first of all this
Baltimore defense let's not be fooled by
what we saw last week it's still the
best defense at football for my money
they played a special team with a
special game plan in the New Orleans
Saints and really one of the few teams
in football that can really match up
with the Ravens defense that in that
capacity
ok the the Carolina Panthers I know
they're one of the better running team
in football certainly I just I got a
sees it too believes it okay because
that Ravens run D their front seven they
got more big [ __ ] than anybody in
football yes sir and I'd look at that I
look at hey the secondary the guys being
banged up there that does scare me a
little bit but I still don't look at the
Carolina offense as being this explosive
offensive passing attack that's gonna
necessarily take advantage of if they if
a guy does sit out the game or whatever
it may be
there's just too many things I like
about this Ravens defense now you flip
it over on the other side Carolina's
defense is extremely good as well
there's no doubt about that huh
I do but they're not on the level of the
Ravens there's a square notch above the
Carolina Panthers on the defensive side
of the ball
I think the Ravens will have a hard time
moving the ball and the Panthers as well
I do I don't think they're gonna be able
to expose the Panthers in any way but I
think at the end of the day the only way
I could see the Panthers winning this
football game is if Cam Newton and the
run game go off and with Superman
there's always a chance because they can
always pull out a few plays that the
Ravens are gonna go damn they didn't run
that quarterback run this year that that
design whatever it may be and all sudden
he goes around the corner for a 50-yard
gain and all of a sudden now you got a
defensive coordinator going holy [ __ ] I
gotta change my game plan a little bit
on defense cuz they got two or three Cam
Newton run plays that I can't play this
defense against what they're doing so at
the end of the day I'm only going $50
I'm going with the Ravens Carolina I
think it's gonna be extremely close
football game
I think the Ravens are the more
desperate team here you know they're
there that was a big loss for them last
week and I think they went 20 to 17
after the Ravens lost to the Bengals
they came back the next week and
destroyed the Broncos 27 to 14 right
after their loss to the Browns they came
back and destroyed the Titans 21 to
nothing the Ravens have not lost
back-to-back games yet this
season Carolina started off down 17
nothing to Washington and tried to claw
back and didn't win Carolina started off
down 17 and nothing and came back and
got the win over the Eagles
it's an emotional week in Carolina yeah
Eric Reed was calling out Malcolm
Jenkins our own master took a picture
from a Philadelphia reporter in which
they did a caricature of Eric Reid and
brought it down to the locker room and
that became a story I'm going the Ravens
here - - in Carolina because I think
that and I'm only going $50 I'm going
$10 on Baltimore this is a game of which
I believe Baltimore's the better team
this is a game which I've listened to
you and you told me that Baltimore
controlled the New Orleans game yeah
Carolina's offense is not New Orleans
office Carolina's offense as we saw last
week is we might not figure it out for
three downs cam save us on fourth down I
don't want to have that philosophy going
up against the Baltimore Ravens the only
thing that I'm scared about it's in
Carolina and but you know what I like
the Baltimore Ravens but I'm only going
$10 I think they win this game outright
I'm taking it to the Baltimore Ravens
cool okay I got a really good one at 405
for you the two and five Indianapolis
Colts on the road visiting the one in
five Oakland Raiders spread in this game
is Colts minus three and whether in
Oakland on Sunday so this is an
interesting one we've got a.m. clouds
and p.m. Sun this is gonna be a 1:05
kickoff in Oakland I don't know where in
the p.m. the Sun is supposed to come out
but just something to keep in mind could
be cloudy could be sunny okay I'll tell
you what if the sun shining on one of
these teams it's the colts okay if it's
gonna be cloudy
it's a Raiders game Ryan grant Malik
Hooker Adam Vinatieri all missed
practices very underrated story Adam
minute areas a few points away from
breaking the all-time points record and
he's hurt so history's gonna come and
I'll tell you what if I got a backup
kicker kicking on a baseball field that
could be an issue for the Colts yeah
Jack Doyle back practice should have
grass back on the field this time of the
year
oh they cover up the dirt usually do yes
right yeah clinic season is over it is
over such big Yankees sent them
Colet CEO semele did miss practice and
again the raiders are coming off of a by
the raiders they trade Amari Cooper
their their locker room is having
arguments is derrick karr emotional Sims
Colts - three in Oakland yeah okay I
mean I think the biggest thing you got
to talk about is what are the Raiders
right now does have they given up on
their season is that over or would they
think their coach is a jerk-off I mean
there's just so many things there that I
just go I don't know what to expect from
the Raiders a little like the Giants
though it might unite the team and they
might go out there and have the best
game of the year that's what I look at
on that way okay so and I still think
that you know Gruden that offense it
still got potential
even without Amari Cooper you know I
know it was a dumpster fire in London it
was horrible but again it's still an
offense that's been for the most part of
the year been able to move the ball as
long as they don't have self-inflicted
inflicted wounds I don't look at this
Colts defense as a defense that's
necessarily the greatest pass rushing
defense I've ever seen but they do get
after the quarterback and that does
scare me a little bit the Colts have
more players on their defense than the
Raiders
so guys Leonard Marcus hunt yes yeah I
do Colts were the offensive line of the
week last week yeah the kid the kid
Walker next to Darius Leonard is really
good so I like that okay
now I go to the other side of the ball I
had no faith in the Raiders defense none
absolutely not
there's not a good pass rusher they
can't stop the run and I know really I
don't expect the Colts to be able to run
the ball on the the Raiders that much
either cuz they're not a great run team
Marlin Mac looks pretty special he did
but that was again last week that was
good it was the bills the bills defense
was on the field like every fourth play
and I think eventually just the dam
broke but I look at it more than
anything and just go this is the type of
game Andrew Luck can take over and I'm
not betting against Andrew Luck in this
type of scenario no way how much you go
I don't feel great about this I'm going
$50 on the Indianapolis Colts because I
picked the score to be 3128 Colts Wow
and I just think you're just too much I
really good score by you too many
hundred percent what it feels like
I feel like a 31-28 game I will go $50
on the Colts no Colonel Andrew Luck
steed come up here real quick yes this
is Becky Becky's been by my side for
four score and two years Becky Becky but
they get here take a little carrot Becky
so the scary thing if we're looking at
spreads here is that Andrew Luck since
his rookie year on the west coast four
and ten in October yeah also the Colts
are bad on the west coast but really it
came down to this for me yeah
the Raiders like I thought about the
pregame speech this is where my betting
mine goes to and John Gruden's gonna go
up there and he's gonna go fellows we
got to go out there and we got a win we
got to do this
and I gotta go these guys are gonna be
looking at him going what [ __ ] are you
talking about
meanwhile the Colts got their first real
convincing win of the season right where
they beat up Buffalo and they were able
to feel the power of a win Marlin Mack
was clicking the young offensive line
was moving people shout out to you for
saying that Braden Smith was gonna be a
tackle because he played really damn
well thank ya and that was he played
guard in college and he moved out well
also they got some turnovers they got
their hands on the ball they're playing
a team with martavis Bryant and Jordy
Nelson as the one in twos nobody knows
what's going on with Derek Carr I just
think that they're definitely gonna win
this game and I think that you're a
hunter sent right I'm seeing Andrew Luck
running around like a Mustang just not
feeling any pressure and just
diagramming up some place do you think
somebody like naheem Hines is gonna come
back or is this more of a Marlin Mac
show I think this will be a Marlin Mac
show more from here on out Mac is ooh
he's an undervalued runner he's got a
little more speed than I don't forgive
me yeah and he's got a little more power
than people for our fantasy team right
because Marshawn Lynch is done we have
what's-his-name the the pass catching
back
jaelyn rishard Jayla rashard right
pickup yeah I've had him I've had him on
the bench now for a few weeks but Jalen
Rashard and Doug Martin I think Rashard
could have a lot of catches could be a
big game for him I think so good that
feels good about that picket
alright guys 425 the one-in-six San
Francisco 49ers on the road by the way
one in 6 Arizona Cardinals speaking of
49ers and speaking of fantasy yes yes so
one of the movements yesterday was a
quote came out that George Kittel stood
next to Aaron Donald air and Donald was
like man you get that touchdown and
George Kendall said I had to man my
fantasy owners needed more points and
the fantasy community is loving it well
I was going back and forth with George
Kindle and the DMZ yesterday because he
asked me bro did you really get tattoos
I said calm down calm down Sims is the
only man here that got tattoos so I
messaged him I said I just want you to
know George as thousands of people are
celebrating you for telling Aaron Donald
you had to get more fantasy points I was
someone that lost because you got too
many so [ __ ] you and he responded with
the laughing emoji and wrote serves you
right for not drafting me and I was like
you're always right kiddo and then he
said when you guys coming back for a
rematch so we might have to go out there
to San Francisco Natalie him and Taylor
he's quickly becoming one of my more
favorite players in football two things
about the Niners spread in the weather
they should be forced to wear those
jerseys they were last week every game
right the All Whites with the gold red
and black drop shadow I think is one of
the cleanest uniforms
I like the red version of that maybe a
little bit more but maintaining the drop
shadow but George Kittel he's top five
Titan in my book he definitely not even
close blocking physical hands
explosiveness and he's doing it with CJ
Beathard yes like he is a phenomenal I
mean he's doing it the right way and
he's Iowa tough Iowa tough cuz he's we
saw him I mean he's a made up 248 pounds
likes if he stopped lifting weights he'd
be 225
yeah but he's one of those guys that
just crushes Chinese food and then
crushes the gym and doesn't that's his
mom yeah yeah and his blocking is
amazing I mean it's all it's all effort
it's not like he's just got engaged
these are clicking
okay yeah I think Oh for George way to
go spreading this game is San Francisco
- one do you want to know the weather in
Glendale or should we skip the weather
for this one I honestly hate this game
I'm going ten dollars on Arizona plus
one and I'm done
90 degrees in Glendale on Sunday Wow
yeah I just I don't want to I don't want
a bet on CJ Beathard I don't want to bet
on Josh Rosen I don't want a bet in a
divisional game I'm taking the home team
plus the points ten dollars in Arizona
yeah I mean I couldn't put ten cents on
Arizona
so I'm putting I'm putting a hundred
dollars on the 49ers really yeah what
what what dynamite come on Shanahan or
shadow my right eye okay Byron Leftwich
I'm not I just I have no faith in
Arizona's offense
the reason they beat the 49ers a few
weeks ago was cuz the CJ Beathard
turnovers and turnovers in general yes a
lot of them fumbles that turn into
touchdowns so this is scary
I get it I don't trust this human
turnover and CJ Beathard I mean that's
what he is it's really very scary but I
also look at it like okay the Cardinals
they can't stop the running at all and
with Kyle and that offense and that
offensive line is still good that scares
me
the 49ers defense is better than people
realize and I'm not saying it's a
special defense but really it always
looks like they are lit up a lot of
points and do things like that more
times than not it's because CJ Panthers
put them in a tough spot and give seems
easy touchdowns or short field when you
watch you go oh there's an Arik Armstead
explosive play there D'Elia there's a
DeForest Buckner explosive play
oh there's Warner with a hell of a
tackle behind the line of scrimmage
that's right yeah I think there's only a
few games on the schedule right now that
the 49ers you look at it and go we could
we should win this game and I think this
is one of them right here and I'm just
gonna go with yes I don't know what the
Arizona
offense and I think it's very fair of
you to go I don't see Arizona sweeping
this series I don't and I'm picking the
49ers to win the game 27 to 20 and
that's why I put $100 on the 40 thank
you all right guys last game of the
afternoon slate here Packers on the road
visiting the 7 and OH
Los Angeles Rams spread in this game Los
Angeles is a nine point favorite and it
is gonna be 80 degrees and partly cloudy
in LA on Sunday three mile an hour winds
so should not be a factor
not a single Packer missed practice on
Wednesday the Rams were missing three
Jair Alexander's back right everybody
shod breeland's back ronimal Allison
Randall Cobb Cooper kaaba's Cooper cup
is missing practice Michael brokers
missing practice anomic ensue did not
practice what his sins gonna do here uh
you want to go first or second I don't
care whatever you want go first okay
largest underdog spread of Aaron Rodgers
career ever yeah well that's not
surprising I mean the Packers defense
has to answer the bell in this football
game let it P let up way too many big
plays in the last few weeks and have
been getting shredded now really the
health of some of those guys is gonna be
paramount to them having a good football
game that's good that they're going to
be out there hold on I'm just pulling
something up there we go okay either way
this is the way I look at it
hey the Packers are I think got
questions I think Mike McCarthy's the
kind of coach that will not let his
teams like sleepwalking the by the by
weeks I'm playing that into a faction
like Sean Payton last week like red ass
red asses hard asses hard ass coaches
like that I feel like usually they're a
little bit better coming out of the by
either way they're also gonna realize
they're not as good as the Rams so I do
think they'll push the envelope on the
offensive side of the ball maybe do a
few things to go okay we got to do this
this week because we can't sit here and
go oh we're only gonna stuff the Rams
offense to 20 points yes
good luck no way no way that's happening
so I look at that the other thing I look
at the Packers and go you know what what
helps them in this matchup
the Packers can pass protect I don't
think that
like Erin Donald and sue and brokers or
going to be living in the back field go
ahead what do us I also thought about
that yeah if I want to Aaron Rodgers to
get pressured up the middle I like when
he runs sure I like when he escapes out
of the pocket does though said I hear
you all the way
I would rather Rodgers be able to escape
the pocket and throw than be forced to
stay in the pocket with a container
right did you like how left go raised
his hand yeah that was nice he's really
he's growing up in his age it's very
nice to see I mean I'm literally
jiggling my legs because I have to pee
but yeah I'm growing up yeah growing up
so like a toddler I look at that and go
those are positives for the Packers sure
the Rams are really awesome and even
when they let up yards I mean they make
plays on defense they really do and 49 I
just have no I don't see how the Packers
can slow down the Rams attack completely
in this football game sure I would worry
about their run defense sure the Rams
are phenomenal running football team in
fact everyone thinks they're like the
greatest show on turf am i right they're
the number-one run offense in the sport
right if so okay
so with all that said I'm putting $100
on the Green Bay Packers $100 that's all
I think the Rams will win this game 35
to 31 okay I think the Packers give a
great effort yeah I couldn't go hard 9
was a lot of points yes but this game
could be 31 31 yes and the Rams go down
and score and make it 38 31 and then
Aaron Rodgers has to throw the ball and
Aaron Donald sack fumbles oh and then
they scored another touchdown and lose
by 14 yes
so this game could be one of those games
that's very close but I would say as a
better it's very dangerous
I look at it like this I am going 150
dollars on the Green Bay Packers yep the
Rams are one in three against the spread
the last four weeks they are undefeated
but they are not covering the spread
well this year they're four and three
against the spread they've had huge
lines all year yeah the way I look at it
is simple like this Chris Sims Aaron
Rodgers offer by the
leg is feeling good yeah the team is
healthy ready to roll and he's in his
old hood he's playing in California
where the sun is shining bright and if
you roll with left go then your bets are
always right
the Rams this year I've let up points
when they play quarterbacks with stuff
yeah
rivers and cousins and Russell Wilson
thrice kina made it to yeah but Aaron
Rodgers with some time can really shred
the gnar and when he plays the Rams I'm
sure that he will set the bar
you-you-you-you yeah I got I I went you
know what the Rams are a hundred percent
gonna put up 33 I think that the Packers
are gonna put up about 27 no I think
your point about you know good
quarterback yes against oh they shut out
the Raiders we see what the Raiders are
they had 13 points I didn't shut out the
Raiders who say they shut him out 13
points they shut out the Cardon right
will she do yes Sam Bradford then they
they held the Niners to 10 they let up
22 Case Keenum and they had to run the
ball to survive that game yeah
31 the Russell Wilson 31 to Kirk Cousins
23 to Phillip Rivers and that one could
have been a lot more if the receivers
didn't drop the ball right so I think
Aaron Rodgers comes in here it's the
game of their year it's the Rams are
feeling high and mighty I know they're
often is gonna go off the keep to leave
is still out yeah
I'm not taking 9 and I'm not taking 9 if
I'm Aaron Rodgers are you kidding me
Aaron Rodgers are gonna put on a show
here in Rogers gonna put on a show I
love this game hundred fifty I'm making
that a lot too yeah ok so back from the
bathroom yeah and I got some news on my
phone ok
the NFL has fired down judge Hugo Cruz
it is the first time in the Super Bowl
era that the NFL is fired and official
in the middle of the regular season is
that the guy from the resident number
one thing they're pointing out is a
missed false start on Russell o Kuhn in
the Chargers Browns game that led to a
touchdown the number one play that I
brought up that said swung the game
right watch the play right there right
you can see member it just jumps off so
blatantly right and not called the fact
that I spent
ten minutes on this and then the guy
ends up getting fired like weeks later
unbelievable that's unbelievable I
wonder is it I wonder what else there
was in there I wonder if they're
listening
did you hear what this Lefko kids might
be listening Hugo
get up here listen what left I said okay
two more games to go here senator Chris
balls make five and one New Orleans
Saints on the road I wasn't crazy
visiting the for two and one Minnesota
Vikings so this is Sunday Night Football
Chris will be on TV before the game
great freakin games cutting this game is
Minnesota minus one and the weather in
Minnesota it's gonna be a high of 48 low
of 35 showers in the morning none of it
matters though cuz they're playing
indoors left go give us the injuries max
Unger missed practice on Wednesday with
a hand left tackle Terron Armstead was
limited and repeat full participant even
though he had a concussion all right
that'll be big Dalvin cook I'd heard him
last week how much did he miss I think
he missed the whole game really I'm
pretty sure unless he unless he was in
there maybe early on and I missed him
and now it's actually gonna drive me
crazy and I have to look real quick
because I'm feeling paranoid so give me
two seconds I'm gonna pull up the film
and just make a look here cuz well
Dalvin cook is out anthony bar and
xavier really didn't play the game
either play that anthony bar and xavier
Rhodes did not practice on Wednesday and
again this is a Vikings team that also
lost Mike Hughes right all right mr.
Sunday Night Football Iverson Griffin's
back Everson Griffin is back we don't
know if he's gonna play right he was a
full participant in practice yesterday
but I know I'll be interested to see if
he plays either way
what's your breakdown in the pregame
show do you know I know I'm gonna be
breaking down I think the Saints offense
to a big-time extent and then I'm not
exactly sure what we're doing with the
Vikings right they gonna make you say
that Michael Thomas is not a top-10
receiver on national primetime
television I don't think so but if I
gotta say it I'll say it I'll do what I
gotta do
but yeah I know it's amazing
either way hey remember that time you
did something bad yeah let's talk about
it the the the this is an awesome game
we know that it is I know people have
been saying like the whole revenge game
there's no revenge here first of all
let's just get over that
the Saints aren't looking at this and
like this is wasn't like you know Saints
got cheap-shotted by Vikings players or
the Vikings ran up the score on them but
Saints are gonna look back at last
year's game and go man we blew it we
just we've messed up some situational
football we should have won that game
that's the only thing they got really
there to look at all right Eagles I mean
the Vikings the Vikings offense they
can't run the ball you know I know they
broke a run against the the Jets last
week and did some good things I'm still
not sitting there going oh I have
confidence in this run game yet
and especially not against the Saints
defense so that's one thing I look at
and I think for that too it helps out
the Saints I think the Saints will air
on if you watch the Vikings they rely on
the big play too much in my opinion they
are very inconsistent
don't let the 37 points from last week's
fool you they it was close the Jets had
a ton of chances exactly right and the
Vikings had the ball like inside the
30-yard line on the Jets a few times and
like only came away with like two field
goals I mean it was yeah it was 20 to 10
there was some bad mistakes by saying
Donald the Jets kind of messed the game
up more than anything I'm not trying to
take away anything of the Vikings but my
big thing with the Minnesota Vikings is
they are an inconsistent offense that's
not as a good offense as last year last
year they were the one of the best
running teams in the NFL also their
system was better the only thing that
their offense is worse this year the
only thing that they have that's better
is Kirk Cousins Kirk Cousins is a baller
and he is [ __ ] all over Washington
by going how dare you like they're just
it's just [ __ ] everywhere okay
I don't know otherwise I covered in fees
right but if you really think about them
and I know I broke this down a little
the other day just you know if we go
back for people who haven't listened you
know last week start the game off with a
bomb down the right sideline - feeling
ok latavius Murray breaks the big run I
got that all Jack Robinson big throw to
the left side you know - Eagles game
defensive touchdown Eagles game you know
big pass plays in that game not a lot of
sustained drives you know I'll even go
to the Packers game in the fourth
quarter it was just
cuz it's making unbelievable place is
the Saints defense though a good team to
go big plays again it could be I would
think the Saints are going
I would think Sean Payton and Alan would
look at this and go I think we could
hang in there and every aspect of this
game let's not put Ken Crawley in too
many positions throw let feel and go by
yeah that's all they do is attack him
and I have a suspect we see you live a
lie Apple over there
a good amount right away from Jump
Street how much you putting on the
Saints okay so then the other side of
the ball is the Vikings defense is still
really good writers it is I mean and
they're actually there run defenses in a
lot of ways been more impressive than me
this year than it was last year Saints
can let I mean the Vikings can let up
some big plays as well but I just think
at the end of the day I'm gonna bet $100
on the New Orleans Saints
I just think New Orleans is a better
football team do we missed out in the
Super Bowl last year in Minnesota so
we're gonna go to Atlanta this year okay
I don't know but either way either way
yes I think this Saints team is special
and I think their offense is as
dangerous as ever
in a physical way that Taysom Hill
aspect their past game I think this game
stays close but I'm picking the Saints
to win 32 27 hmm I am putting 150
dollars on the Saints
I can feel it in the bones the Saints
are gonna go to Minnesota make it their
home because it's drew Brees manganese
smoke the trees and be the breezes Drew
Brees and the Saints yeah you are you
got it you're a good flower catamaran
you're gotta rhymes get it I know that
you think that the revenge doesn't
matter yeah but it remains to me in this
way yeah if I had just gone into
Baltimore and beaten the team like the
Ravens I would want to make sure that my
team would still be motivated and
wouldn't get too high on a win yeah and
nothing can get you more motivated than
going back to the scene of the crime and
facing a Vikings team that you think
that you're better than sure that you
should focus
I don't list the [ __ ] suffice yeah
also I believe that Sean Payton is gonna
have some wild stuff drawn up for this
game I believe that Sean Payton is going
to try and embarrass the Vikings I think
that he is gonna study the Sean McVeigh
film from when they hung up 38 on them
and go I am gonna push these pressure
points to a tee they have girly I have
Kimora they have girly I also have
Ingram they have their wide receivers I
can spread all my guys all over the face
they are gonna they're gonna stress out
Anthony bar
they are gonna stress out the weak parts
of the defense and they're down corners
I think the Saints offense is going to
be clicking yeah I think Kirk Cousins is
gonna feel a little bit of pressure
right up the gut
I think the Saints might win this game
by double digits I think that the other
thing about the Saints yeah the Saints
in October their last 15 games in
October the Saints are 14 and one
against the spread
Wow thirteen and two straight up Wow
there are certain parts of the calendar
year that certain teams do well the
Saints are one of the most consistent
teams to bet on for and against
repetitively beginning of the year they
lose games they shouldn't write this
time weeks four through nine Sean Payton
is freaking crews like Belichick because
he's seen everybody's pieces his team is
where it needs to be and he's operating
at a high level we're in a dome
drew brees is feeling good right now
nice and warm nice and warm and I think
the Vikings are you know feeling
themselves a little bit right I think
that Drew Brees goes in there and I
think they win this game by 16 really
like a like you're thinking like a 35 21
other thinking it's good it's gonna be a
little bit feeling like Kansas City
Cincinnati where it's like score for
both teams and then the Saints score and
they get another one right before the
half and they get the ball back at half
time and by the time you look up there
at they're up there up 17 and it's the
vikas ins trying to throw them back into
it that's how I look okay all right guys
last game of the weekend to break down
here Monday Night Football
Saints we're destroying them what I mean
in that playoff game I know the Vikings
jumped out to a big lead right
but once the Saints Scout rolling yeah
the Vikings couldn't do anything yeah I
think that's the game that continues
this time okay I think Taysom Hill runs
in for two touchdowns excuse me my bold
prediction Taysom Hill is gonna run for
a touchdown
and throw for a touch spicy I might pick
him up my fantasy team and DoubleDown
bold thanks bro all right guys Monday
Night Football the booger crane is
headed to Buffalo the five and to the
wing with Patriots taking on these two
and five Buffalo Bills spread in this
game New England minus 14 and the
weather in Buffalo on Monday not sunday
screwed that up last week it's gonna be
showers in Buffalo on Monday night 44
degrees is the high 37 is the low 13
mile an hour winds
we're gonna go to Sims first on this one
because there's no injuries for no
injuries
take it away Chris what do I say about
this game what do I say what do I say
what do I say what is there to say I
mean what is there to say the bill stink
I mean do you want to bet all your money
or bet a quarter of your money I just I
don't know but buffalo has no oh okay so
they must go and New England's Catching
Fire and their DS good
and the office I don't even care of Sony
Michelle I know he's not gonna be out
there great it doesn't matter they still
got other running backs let me find ok I
don't I I this was the Shocker of the
week to me what did you think it
should've been 21 I was like what it's
only 14 that's right I was like I wrote
down the score to be 38 to 13 and I was
like man should I make it more I was
like no one gonna probably pull off the
gas pedal at some point and just be like
okay let's just forget about it okay I
mean I don't know I actually got scared
that it was 14 I was like is there
something I don't know is there an
injury did like I don't I don't even get
it all right so we're both gonna be in
the same boat here I bought four hundred
dollars to come at this hour gone over
your ass again barrels you suck you suck
you suck you suck that's awesome
Thank You Nikki that's a good one
nothing reinvigorates me like a new
sound like that I love that that was
great there I've seen where Paul Revere
are you betting $400 man feeling really
good about it I mean I don't know I even
know how much money you got left you've
gotten 150 and 10 the whole damn day I
got laughs I went over to Dana and I
said should I be afraid of the Buffalo
Bills at all because this doesn't make
sense to me this is Derrick Anderson and
a banged-up LaShawn boy who's gonna like
us because I think sometimes I go to the
super fans of a team because they'll go
you know what it's always weird with the
bills yeah yeah but I didn't get that
this time right I understand it's a big
time line the over-under is 44 and so in
my head I said what's more likely thirty
four to ten or twenty four to twenty
thirty four to ten five hundred percent
I also thought oh no Sony Michelle that
could be a benefit because no Sony
Michelle means we're not running out the
clock yeah that means we're throwing
with James White all the freaking time I
will see your four hundred and I will
put five hundred down on the New England
pageant not want to be one out hello hi
Brady I come to score the points I'm
suddenly Irish and I'll mess with you
all your joints rise for a coach Bill
Belichick coach how do you feel today to
all the good people I shall smite down
Derrick Anderson and put his head on
this stick man Boston history is amazing
it's amazing super weird
why's it weird I don't know I mean they
only started the freaking country for us
I get it just a lot of fighting man I'd
rather calm down well they had a fight I
mean I get it yeah I know I'm just
saying that like when your town and city
is the center of like thousands like
hundreds of years of fighting and
revolutions and stuff yeah a lot of
people there are tense
yeah that's why they're all kind of
crazy yeah I don't know but they're
[ __ ] awesome with sports in that down
all three championships in the majors
for soccer deltax and BJ's holy crap but
I look at this game and I go the only
way I mean I even went back and thought
about how maybe the Patriots got a
little lucky against the Bears well
those two interceptions were kind of
lucky they did get a kickoff return for
a touchdown they did fumble on that one
kickoff and I went man you know maybe
they aren't that good and I thought it's
the Patriots
it's Monday Night Football they're
playing the Buffalo Bills with a backup
quarterback a backup running back
am I afraid of Chris Ivory running for a
hundred and fifty yards and two
touchdowns and I'm just not like I was a
hundred percent going to bet like 1410
on this and ten dollars or were twelve
eighty and ten dollars and everything
else and I just got a little bit afraid
like five hundred dollars is my afraid
bet yeah people people love your take on
the monday night football crew yesterday
oh yeah what were they saying a lot of
people saying thanks for being honest
about the crew I can't watch the games
it's the can I tell you the hardest
thing that I have with them
a football crew and if I've already said
this stop me when I watch Collinsworth
and I watch Romo and I watch these I
stop you said it already tonight now but
when I watch those guys they're gonna
bring me something I haven't seen before
and that when something crazy happens
they explain it and I go oh that makes
sense
so when Collinsworth one second after
breelan speaks let's go of Tom Brady
goes look at this he had them and it's
the rule and I went oh I didn't really
notice that and then they show the
replay I go damn you know what you're
absolutely right that sucks but when I
watch the Giants Falcons game and they
go for two and then for like the next
six minutes I have to listen to booger
talk about how that was the wrong
decision instead of talking about the
game or the fact that they run a jet
sweep on the one-yard line and Jason
Witten goes I actually understand the
play call and I vehement ly disagree
with the television I'm not trusting you
anymore I've always believed that you
are in those positions because you see
football at a different level than the
common human being
Phil can do that you can do that
Collinsworth can do that Romo can do
that Aikman can do that where they see
the game and they diagnose it in a
second and then they can explain it more
but as a fan if I'm watching a game and
I believe that I might see the game as
well as you or maybe better than you
well now you're a disservice because now
you're making me question things that I
know are not questionable you're not
enlightening me you're dimming me if
that makes sense like do you feel that
way too
not gonna be as hard critical you're not
as real as me no it's okay well I I will
say this they it's it's early on and you
know what and maybe that's the reason
we're so angry with Cruden not only is
he like torn apart a franchise traded
all their stars for draft picks but like
we went from a Monday night football
where I would stick around for the
postgame because I want to see who the
Gruden grinder is and John's gonna show
up like a seven year old clip of a
turkey hole throw and I'm gonna learn
something and right now I watch Monday
Night Football and all I'm hearing is
what
and I just don't like it alright let's
wrap it up here guys I'm gonna go
through the disagreements we'll come
over to left go through the locks and
then we'll have more money on the
Patriots than really bums me out
so yeah okay it bothered me that he
one-up me on the past 100 yeah it really
did III wanted to up one up you there
alright guys so disagreements this week
while we're working on now doc DTL let
go let go you are going with the Jaguars
plus three Sims took Philly - coming
portals I'm going $10 you're going a
hundred yeah Denver at KC Sims wet with
Denver left go went with KC minus ten
and we have an extra $20 action on the
hash money
Tampa Bay at Cincinnati I don't know why
you guys picked this game to disagree on
Tampa Bay plus four and a half for Simms
left go Cincinnati - four and a half
fifty each jets at Chicago Simms went
with the Bears - seven left go you took
the Jets plus seven
I went ten you went 50 right and then
into the afternoon games here the last
disagreement of the week San Francisco
at Arizona Sims going with the Niners -
one and left go took the Cardinals plus
one so on hard to roses you can't help
it when our disagreements I have ten ten
fifty ten and a hundred so in our
disagreements I have a hundred and
eighty combined all our disagreements
right your locks for this week and I am
more than that yeah my locks I am going
to go Kansas City - ten against Denver I
am going to go Detroit - three Hosting
Seattle I am going to go
the Packers plus nine at the Rams and
I'm gonna go the Saints plus one in
Minnesota and laughs go you know what
time it is I do it's time to go -
guaranteed to lose land fire up that
funky music Nick
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba
we've got $20 on the game of Susan's in
care because he's still taking a giggy's
Keenum you're hired
you can that go now okay I can go now
beg you let's go ah Denver welcome to
guaranteed to lose you're gonna lose why
cuz Kansas that he's better and my homes
is awesome I think you'll keep it close
let go things you own but I think you
keep it close nonetheless you get the
Big L like a elver left go sorry
speaking of L's there's one franchise
that should call themselves the Browns
the blonds oh I like it the Browns yes
you're not going into Pittsburgh black
and yellow black and yellow
Pittsburgh's motivated they see a
glimmer they know that they have a
chance in the AFC and the Browns are
going in the wrong direction sorry
Cleveland
I don't believe lend this week there's
nothing I like more that when sim says
he doesn't trust the game and then picks
that team guaranteed to lose then New
York Giants how can you trust that dumps
their fire sorry
even Phil Simms says you're gonna lose
this one Giants I don't know what the
hell's going down there you've abandoned
the season and eli manning's your
quarterback I just can't picture you an
ink sorry New York giant I can thing I
like is when Sims bets against the front
of the podcasts and Arnold prove them
wrong hey stalker alert stay away from
him Sam let go is a stalker stage night
clear don't listen to what he says but
sorry Jets you're a good football team
you're gonna be better next year but the
Bears are pissed off and haven't played
good the last two weeks you gonna lose
you know why because I said so and the
last one the combined $900 bet against
this team it is the Buffalo Bills Bills
you're gonna lose I don't know what to
say yeah two L's in your name bills LLL
s and then you're gonna lose as Tom
Brady's coming it down sorry there's no
freaking chance you're winning this game
hashtag Tommy greater than Derrick sorry
you lose see you next week Buffalo that
was Sims turning into a robot brought to
you by H&M the only video store run
by a lot of people that you don't want
to talk to B&H what were you laughing up
there bill spelled bi l LLS yeah I added
the extra L they have Buffalo right oh
you're right they do three hours for
ELLs if you add the alder for the loss
of ice so how do you feel about my locks
I don't feel good about him did any of
them know who would you have locked the
New England Patriots
I can't I'm sorry okay but what do you
think about Detroit scary Green Bay
scary I don't like any of these this
week I looked at all these lines and I
was like they're all dicey yeah well
that doesn't help I know and that's
whatever all right guys thank you as
always I'm gonna have pendrick put this
as an image out on Twitter tomorrow yeah
you've had a lot of people asking they
want to keep track as the games are
going on so he's gonna put out a picture
of the spreadsheet with all of our bets
and Sims is only ten dollars behind can
he catch me and surpass me we shall fine
you go put my scores out there too if
you want and don't forget to check out
sims on Sunday Night Football we will
take some screenshots as should you
we'll do some Sims memes before New
Orleans versus Minnesota for Sims
peace out homies Hendrick would say good
evening everybody and the lef koe man
says holla at you later go Eagles beat
the crap out of the Jaguars in the
morning seriously seriously